these wide swamps near Charleston South
Carolina were long a blight on the
landscape and a breeding ground for the
malaria carrying mosquitoes the
Anopheles Quadra maculatus here water
and vegetation met and malaria drained
the vitality of the people living nearby
here the malaria danger signal flash
during hot summer months and the land
was worse than useless
week after week inspectors waded through
these swamps dipping for larvae
the larvae were collected in files to be
transported to a laboratory for
examination larvae sighting was
necessary when the count was high and it
was usually high
these repetitive measures were a
continual drain on public health funds
and public health officials became
convinced but permanent elimination of
the problem by drainage was necessary
and economically feasible malaria
control engineers located the ditches
and established grades
labor crews following the engineers dug
the main ditch from the outlet to the
swamp the initial cut was vertical sides
of the ditch were sloped to a grade
determined by the stability of the soil
and the bottom was fine graded to ensure
a smooth flow of water
excavated material was spread evenly
along the banks so that water could not
collect behind it and to keep the spoil
from washing back into the ditch the
main ditch was put into service by
making an entrance cut or tapping the
pond good engineering and proper
construction paid off as the water moves
smoothly and rapidly out of the swamp
the completed main ditch with its smooth
well sloped sides and spoil spread
evenly along the banks is a good example
of hand ditching smaller areas were
drained into the main ditch by laterals
or side ditches these were also dug from
the outlet to the swamp the pond was
tapped and the water drained off in a
steady flow
to enter the main ditch at angles
designed to avoid any disturbance of
flow in either ditch abrupt angles were
avoided and the discharge enters the
main ditch a few inches above its bottom
complete drainage of this area has made
reproduction of the malaria mosquito
impossible this is no longer a problem
area the land has been reclaimed and its
development may offset the entire cost
of the project here hand itching was the
practical answer to malaria control